it's great to understand the numbers
because your metrics are the foundation
that you need in order to make the right
decisions for your business however
sometimes even the numbers can be
worthless if you can't really explain
why certain metrics are moving or why
things are happening this is when you
want to hear from any users to get some
qualitative answers and reasons
usertesting.com is a tool that can give
you a wealth of information and insights
into what users are feeling when they
use your products let's hear from Mike
VP of mobility user testing comm about
user testing so why do you want to see
people actually using your app you know
analytics can can tell you wonderful
things and and it's really important to
have the best analytics you can possibly
get but what they tell you is what
people are doing
you don't necessarily learn why so you
may see a problem but you don't
understand why it's happening and then
you end up learning a whole bunch of
different experiments to try to figure
out what's going on and they won't
necessarily get you really quickly to
the right answer whereas if you can
combine the analytics that tell you what
people are doing with the video that
tells you why and what they're thinking
and stuff like that you can much more
quickly get really really good overall
insights that kind of combine both
qualitative and quantitative measures so
it's a way to learn faster so one
example of the sorts of things that
people learn from testing the the
listings for the store is even the art
style of the icons can be really really
important so it's not just what you show
but it's are you doing for instance a
cartoony type version of the icon in
which case that kind of suggests a
certain type of audience and sometimes
you'll find I don't want to be sexist
about this at all but sometimes what we
see is the women sometimes respond
better to something that's a little more
cartoony looking because it feels a
little bit more friendly you know think
of the sort of graphics that you see in
a game like candy crush which is really
aimed at women then sometimes you get
more hard edged graphics down where it's
a little more realistic looking and
maybe you've got if you've got a face
it's a frowning face that looks
aggressive or something like that
sometimes again it's an sexist but the
guys respond better to that sort of
thing and so it's not just what you show
but it's
so how you present it the graphical
style that use the artistic style all
that sort of stuff you need to be very
very conscious of combining analytics
and user tests it's one of them look the
best things one of those fun things that
you can do because the analytics will
give you all sorts of information on
what's happening with your application
and you'll inevitably identify some
places where people are getting stuck oh
they get to the third panel and they
can't figure out what there's just why
are they not clicking on the button it's
so freakin obvious to the design team
right because we worked on it for nine
months now and so it's completely
intuitive us they're not tapping on that
same thing and you'll get disputes
within the team sometimes religious
disputes about well it's the color no no
no it's the design of the icon and you
can go and run like fifteen different a
be tests to try to figure out all that
stuff and spend an enormous amount of
time and what we recommend is instead
when you reach that point we'll run a
few user tests and it doesn't have to be
fifty ok you're not looking for
quantitative stuff this is qualitative
it could be maybe five you know just to
get some reactions from people when they
get any given instructions go to this
screen and then tell me what you're
gonna do this and talk to me about what
you're thinking so don't just watch what
they do but but you can prompt them with
I want you to tell me when you look at
this screen what are you seeing and you
know what do you choose to do next why
do you choose to do that and usually
what you'll find is they're getting
confused or they're getting distracted
by something and half the time it'll be
what somebody was arguing with in the
team and half the time it'll be
something that nobody realized like oh
my oh my goodness that that annoyed them
or that made them feel like they weren't
well connected to it and you know okay
but the good news is you found that out
quickly so you can then for your a B
test that's going to follow your B
version can be a fix to that particular
problem and so with luck maybe you only
have to do one a B test or maybe you
only have to do a couple of rounds in
order to get it to really really work
better so so what it does is it makes
your your analytics and your a B testing
more effective it lets you move through
that stuff faster so you evolve the app
faster you get better quicker and
therefore you able to reach your your
ramp
a lot faster so other things you can do
with user tests the cool thing is you're
not just limited to recording what's on
the screen and getting the users voice
you can also have them turn on the
backside camera so something that we've
done for for some developers is if
you've designed in the app where you you
want it to be taken out into the real
world you can get some context about how
it's being used in those places to give
you an example we did some stuff for one
of the major real estate apps and they
assumed that the app was going to be
used at for home browsing when they're
at people are out looking at homes and
what they found instead was that people
are using at home on the couch to plan
out where they wanted to go and so all
of a sudden you realize the context of
the usage of the application is
different so I'm competing with the
television I'm competing with stuff
that's that's playing on the stereo but
that also means different ways you can
potentially market to those people if
they're using it at home while they're
watching TV Oh what shows do our target
users go after you know are there some
ways we could look for placement or
things like that obviously if you're a
small startup maybe you don't have the
money to look at those sorts of things
but you could still look for rather than
advertising maybe it's placement
opportunities or how do i influence the
people that they that i know that
they're watching or things like that so
the more context you can get around the
life of your user in the situation in
which your stuff is being used the
better you're going to be able to to be
able to tell your stuff exactly to to
what those people are gonna want I think
another thing is you can use it also
just to kind of interview them so
obviously you should be talking to your
customers all the time you should be
meeting with them you should be taking
them out to coffee or doing whatever but
there may be situations where they're
geographically diverse and you want to
see what are people thinking in other
areas you can do a user test that just
ask some questions and ask them to talk
you don't have to have them using your
software it can just be a way to record
a quick interview with these people you
know think of it as focus groups where
you don't have to rent a focus group
facility you don't have to schedule
these people to come in you don't have
to pay them a whole bunch of money to
come in and then by the way half of them
don't show up and you sit there eating
in and while you're waiting for somebody
to come out
and so it can be a way to just get some
dialogue going with your users and get
them talking to you about what they're
thinking so one more interesting use of
these sorts of user tests to be aware of
is that the videos themselves can be
very very persuasive so you may be in a
situation as a marketing person where
you've gotten an insight about how the
customers think but maybe other people
in the company have their own ideas and
you can do the traditional thing we
should you go have a big long argument
with them about a whole bunch of you
know over a whole bunch of different
times to gradually move them over or
what you can do is just forward the
videos around and in fact one small
developer I was talking with the other
day there a company called trove that
does personal property management you
know for kind of like insurance purposes
and stuff like that and so they've got
like a 15 or 20 person staff and they
said well we get together and we do
viewing parties of the videos and
sometimes they're great because they
confirm things that we already thought
and sometimes they're really really
painful but the nice thing is nobody
argues with a user who's saying what
they actually think and you know that
these tests are being really effective
when you get other members of the team
like in the engineers or people like
that coming back and saying you know I
saw this in the video and I think I'm
starting to think this is the direction
we should go because then you're just
educating people you're not having to
argue you're not having to create
friction it's not taking a long time but
naturally the team's coming together
around these insights and to me that's
one of the best uses of these tests